[Music]
so welcome to Kunsan do kadosh a Duke
moonshine University here we are at DK
you in its final months of construction
in the middle of kun Sean in the middle
of Jang su province and I'm here with
dr. Mary Brown Bullock who is the
executive vice chancellor for Duke
Kunshan University and Mary thank you
very much for welcoming I've been here
many times many times right so you've
seen these buildings grow
I've seen these buildings grow and I've
seen grow here I mean I've never
imagined quite frankly it would be as
beautiful as it is his main academic
building but we're in the middle of the
most ambitious American effort in higher
education in China since the building of
yenching university in the late 19th
what's a university that have an
enormous impact on China in the
Republican period and then still today
as the campus of Peking University so
Mary tell us tell us what's behind us
and and what's going on well as bill
said we are in the final months of
construction of Duke Lynch on university
we will open in August 2014 so this may
be aired after that okay and the
building behind you is the centrepiece
of the campus it see we call it the
academic building you can see that it
has I don't know if you can pick up the
fine glass edging but it has some
elements from Suzhou Gardens as well as
having a very distinct modern look and I
think that that's what this campus is
designed to do it'll be a cutting edge
technologically but aesthetically it
tries to draw on the region where in the
joinin region particularly the psuedo
region with canals and lakes you can't
see it here but there will be water
everywhere on campus and instead of a
grass quadrangle we have a lake in the
center of the campus so this is one of
the ways that we're trying to really
develop the elements of the region this
building will house faculty students
auditorium classrooms dining room
it's about two hundred thousand square
feet but as you can also see we have
four additional buildings which will be
opening this fall and we will have
housing for two hundred students at two
hundred bed conference center you're
welcome to come and use our comp thank
you thank you and a service building so
this is really the beginning of Duke
crunch on University and it's phase one
of Duke Kunshan University's phase one
of three on a 200 acre campus right in
the hearts of the fastest developing
part of China between Shanghai and
Nanjing right in the heart of what may
someday be I think a city called nan hi
nan jingzhong or maybe not just the city
because this will ideally remain green
now in terms of getting around it so
much water here will you have gondolas
no I don't think we have beautiful
bridges bridges we have beautiful
bridges that have a little evoke a
chinese bridge feeling but it's actually
true that when you come from the student
dormitory to the classroom you have to
go across two bridges so it'll be kind
of fun yeah I think we will all enjoy
seeing the lake and there its final
manifestations well we're here right
before the opening and this will air
after the opening and we'll know a bit
more at that point how things have gone
but it's it's an extraordinary effort
and extraordinary ambition on the part
of Duke and also on the part of Kanchan
so congratulations you're almost there
we're almost
you